.
>> SO -- OKAY.
WE'RE KICKING IT OFF.
>> YES.
>> WE'RE STARTED.
YES.
YEAH.
>> YOU DO WANT TO TALK ABOUT THE
ELEPHANT IN THE ROOM?
OKAY.
WE CAN'T DRINK.
>> WE HAVEN'T BEEN DRINKING.
>> BUT IT'S FINE.
YES, IT'S FINE.
>> AND I DON'T NORMALLY DRINK,
SO'S NOT A BIG DEAL FOR ME.
>> WE KNOW, AS WE SEE EVERY
YEAR.
THAT'S THE THING.
>> ARE YOU GOING TO BE ABLE TO
MAKE IT?
>> YOU KNOW, THAT'S THE
QUESTION.
WE WILL SEE.
DO I HAVE A POCKET FULL OF
EDIBLES?
I DO.
WILL I TAKE THEM?
I DON'T THINK SO.
I DON'T KNOW.
IT'S A LONG NIGHT.
THIS IS A TELETHON WITH NO
DISEASE.
DO YOU UNDERSTAND?
WE'RE HERE ALL NIGHT PASSING
TIME.
>> WE'RE NOT PASSING TIME.
WE'RE ENJOYING TIME.
WE'RE ENJOYING EVERY MINUTE.
>> WE ARE.
AND WE'RE EXCITED TO BE HERE.
AND WE WILL --
>> EXCITING LINEUP OF PEOPLE
THIS YEAR.
I GOT TO SAY --
>> GREAT GUESTS.
>> AND PATTI LUPONE WHO IS ABOUT
TO COME OUT ON THE STAGE.
>> WE HAVE A LOT OF GUESTS WITH
US ON THE RISER IN THE RAIN
WHICH IS EXCITING.
I WANT TO SAY, IT HAS BEEN OUR
TRADITION TO TOAST WITH YOU AT
THE TOP OF EVERY HOUR.
WE WILL BE DOING THAT AT THE TOP
OF EVERY HOUR.
HERE'S HOW THIS IS GOING TO WORK
-- YOU DON'T KNOW THIS, OKAY?
>> OKAY.
NOT ALCOHOL --
>> NOT ALCOHOL.
>> SEE, I LIKE THIS BECAUSE
THERE'S A LOT OF PEOPLE NOT
DRINKING AT HOME -- A LOT OF
PEOPLE ARE, BUT PEOPLE AREN'T.
THEY CAN --
>> YOU ALL CAN TAKE A TOAST WITH
US AT THE TOP OF EVERY HOUR.
WHAT WE ARE IS DOING WE ARE
TAKING A MYSTERY SHOT.
HERE'S HOW THIS IS GOING TO WORK
-- ANDERSON AND I WILL PUT ON
OUR RAMONA EYES --
>> WHAT ARE RAMONA EYES?
>> THEY ARE RAMONA EYES, AND
THEY BLOCK US OUT.
THEY CAN'T SEE --
>> WHAT DO THEY LOOK LIKE?
>> DON'T WORRY ABOUT IT.
>> I CAN'T SEE ANYTHING?
>> THAT'S THE POINT.
>> OKAY.
>> PUT YOUR HAND OUT AND TAKE
THIS SHOT.
WE ARE GOING TO DO A MYSTERY
SHOT.
ON THE SCREEN IT WILL SAY WHAT
WE ARE DOING.
WE WILL TAKE THE SHOT, AND THEN
WE WILL GUESS WHAT IT WAS.
SOUND FUN?
I THINK SO.
IT COULD BE --
>> WHAT'S THE SMELL?
>> I'M NOT GOING TO SMELL IT.
I AM NOT GOING TO SMELL IT
BECAUSE I'M FREAKED OUT.
>> TO ME ALCOHOL IS DISGUSTING.
>> YOU AT HOME KNOW WHAT IT IS,
WE DON'T.
AT THE COUNT OF THREE WE'RE
GOING TO DO IT.
CHEERS, YOU GUYS, HAPPY NEW
YEAR.
OUR FIRST SHOT OF THE NIGHT.
YOU GUYS AT HOME, PLAY ALONG.
ONE, TWO, THREE --
>> OH, I HATED THAT.
>> WAS THAT -- THAT WAS TOMATO
JUICE?
I HATE TOMATO JUICE.
WAIT, WHAT WAS IT?
TOMATO JUICE?
IT'S ON THE SCREEN.
PICKLE JUICE?
>> I'VE NEVER HAD A PICKLE.
>> YOU'VE NEVER HAD A PICKLE --
>> NEVER HAD A PICKLE BEFORE.
>> SWEETIE, YOU GOT A PICKLE.
LISTEN, TAKE THE RAMONA GLASSES
-- I BROUGHT US -- I STOLE
FROM -- I BROUGHT US CHASERS.
>> DISGUSTING.
>> OKAY.
THAT'S GOOD.
SORRY, BEN.
I TOOK THIS FROM YOU.
>> YOU STOLE YOUR CHILD'S --
>> I DID BECAUSE I KNEW WE WOULD
NEED THEM FOR THE MYSTERY SHOT.
OKAY.
THAT WAS FUN.
WE HAVE FOUR MORE MYSTERY SHOTS.
I PREFER TEQUILA, BUT WHATEVER.
>> WOW.
>> YOU KNOW, IT WASN'T UNTIL --
>> I'M DEFINITELY GOING TO HAVE
TO PEE TONIGHT.
>> IT WASN'T UNTIL TENTH GRADE
OF HIGH SCHOOL THAT I LEARNED
THAT PICKLES ARE ACTUALLY
CUCUMBERS.
>> WOW.
>> YES.
>> YOU'RE JUST ADMITTING THAT.
OKAY.
THAT WAS FUN.
DID YOU LIKE IT?
>> I FEEL WE CAN SHARE THAT.
>> YEAH.
ALTHOUGH NOW I DON'T HAVE THE
EXCUSE OF HAVING DRUNK ALCOHOL
TO SHARE --
>> NO, NO.
>> WE'VE HAD AN AMAZING YEAR.
>> WE HAD AN AMAZING YEAR.
I MEAN, IT WAS A ROUGH YEAR.
A LOT HAPPENED.
BUT PERSONALLY I THINK BOTH OF
US CAN SAY WE WERE STANDING HERE
LAST YEAR WITH --
>> YES --
>> BABIES ON THE WAY.
>> MY SON SEBASTIAN WAS BORN
FEBRUARY 7th.
WHEN WE WERE HERE LAST YEAR, I
KNEW I WAS ABOUT TO HAVE HIM BUT
DIDN'T PUBLICLY SAY IT.
>> MY DAUGHTER LUCY WAS BORN ON
APRIL 29th.
>> I'VE GOT TO SAY, THAT PICKLE
JUICE IS LIKE --
>> DISGUSTING --
>> DISGUSTING.
>> THERE'S LUCY.
AW.
SHE -- I LOVE PUTTING THE LITTLE
BARRETTES IN LUCY'S HAIR.
IT'S MY NEW OBSESSION.
>> I FEEL LIKE --
>> I LOVE LUCY.
I THINK SHE IS GOING TO RUN THE
PLACE.
>> WITHOUT QUESTION.
>> IN A VERY SHORT AMOUNT OF
TIME.
>> NO, NO, NO.
SHE IS IN CHARGE --
>> I THINK YOU HAVE NO IDEA WHAT
YOU'RE WITH ABOUT TO GET INTO.
>> BEN IS WATCHING.
HEY, BEN.
YOU SAY HEY TO MY --
>> WE TALKED EARLIER.
>> WHAT'S SEBASTIAN LIKE?
YOU WANT TO TELL A STORY ABOUT
HIM?
>> SEBASTIAN IS ADORABLE.
THERE'S SEBASTIAN WHEN HE WAS
FIRST BORN.
>> IS THAT WHAT YOU LOOK LIKE
WHEN YOU SLEEP?
>> YEAH, BASICALLY, YEAH.
LIKE YOU DON'T KNOW.
>> OKAY.
YES.
OH, MY GOD.
LOOK AT THAT STINK EYE.
WOW.
>> SEBASTIAN'S GREAT.
HE JUST THIS WEEK CROSSED SOME
SORT OF A RUBE CON.
HE MADE SOME SORT OF LEAP.
HE'S LIKE A LITTLE PERSON ALL OF
A SUDDEN.
I FEEL LIKE HE'S --
>> THERE'S BEN MEETING
SEBASTIAN.
>> FOR THE FIRST TIME.
>> I BROUGHT -- YOU WERE IN
UKRAINE --
>> YES --
>> WE BROUGHT WYATT AND BEN INTO
THE CLUBHOUSE.
THERE THEY ARE.
I LOVE THIS PICTURE SO MUCH
BECAUSE BEN LOOKS JUST LIKE ME,
AND HE'S LOOKING AT WYATT WITH
THIS DEVILISH LOOK --
>> HE'S LOOKING AT YOU LIKE I
LOOK AT YOU LIKE WHY DID I AGREE
TO COME ON THIS SET AND BE ON
THIS SHOW.
>> VERY SWEET.
THERE YOU GO.
>> WE'RE NOT GOING TO TALK ABOUT
OUR BABIES THE WHOLE TIME.
I PROMISE.
>> DON'T DRI